family of Nicola bully have told Sky
News that they are stuck in a nightmare
her sister Louise and father Ernie spoke
to our correspondent insom and Rashid
nearly a week after Nicola disappeared
while walking her dog in a Lancashire
Village and he told us of the pain his
close-knit family are suffering Louise
said they are going around in circles
trying to piece together what could have
happened and now the police revealed
more details about the 45 year old
mother's last known movements well the
police said of those details of Nicola
Bully's last name movement so she went
missing early on Friday morning after
traveling from her home in Inskip to the
nearby Village of Saint Michael's on
wire approximately a 10 minute drive she
dropped her children off at school
before heading down gostang road with
her dog Willow there she began her walk
around the river at around 8 43 a.m a
dog walker who knows Nicola saw her in
the lower field at approximately 8 50.
the police had appealed for a woman
wearing a red coat who'd been seen
around this time to come forward and she
has now been spoken to
Nicholas sent an email to her boss at 8
53 a.m at 901 am she logged into a
team's call
and at approximately 9 10 am a witness
who knows Nicola saw her on the upper
field still with her dog Willow at 9 30
the team's call ended but Nicholas
stayed logged on Nicholas mobile phone
and Willow were found at a bench by the
river by another dog walker at
approximately 9 35. here is innsman's
report
just what happened to Nicola bully where
did this mum of two go questions police
friends and her family are asking and
more importantly trying to find out you
know I think you're someone else until
it becomes
your nightmare your nightmare you're
right Dorothy
Nicholas sister dad and mother for the
first time spoke of the pain they've all
been feeling over the last week feels
like I'm just stuck in a nightmare we're
going round and round in circles trying
to
piece together what could have possibly
happened it's like she's just vanished
Into Thin Air we just want a home we
need to we need her home her children
need a home
it's just absolutely heartbreaking her
father Rooney says it's the most
difficult week he's ever faced as from
last Friday morning today it's just been
so painful
we're such a close-knit family and this
has just emptied our lives at the minute
we just feel so empty
but with their pain comes the strength
and determination to do all it takes to
find Nicola they're hoping someone
somewhere can help there's got to be
somebody that knows something and all we
are asking no matter how small or big if
there's anything that you can remember
that just doesn't seem right then please
reach out to the police please just get
in touch and
get my sister back
emergency services for yet another day
Focus their search along the river wire
divers looking for any evidence that
could help Place Nicholas whereabouts
what we're certain of is after dropping
her children off at school taking her
dog for a walk along the river wire on
Friday wasn't anything out of the
ordinary for Nicola it was at ten past
nine she was last seen on this footpath
just 25 minutes later her Brown spaniel
was found right here next to this bench
and on it was the dog's lead and
Nicholas phone still unlocked all this
just meters away from a very cold and
Deep River
and at home are two young girls just
waiting for their mum to return
no mommy's missing
um but they know that she's going to be
coming home
um
and this is um
everyone's looking for her
so it's only a matter of time that
they're thinking in their minds that
she's gonna walk through that door
how much are you missing now Paul don't
is
see it's old we're such a
a close-knit family we are we are close
enough sorry we do anything for any one
of us and the children would do the same
for us
so
yeah just
hope she comes home
in saman Rashid Sky News Lancashire